[Music]
they've seen the police in Tampa
basically there was an organization by
the protesters that they wanted to
corner those police officers then you
have the situation in Wisconsin we've
seen it in cities all across the country
it's no wonder that many Americans feel
like it's out of control yeah you know
Dana we're in a bad spot right now
everybody can see it everybody can feel
it you know you can call me a crazy
right winger or a scary conservative or
whatever you want to call me but I want
to be very clear with my words here i
100% stand with the police officers who
are in many ways in a no-win situation
here they're trying to do their job they
are by and large 99.9 percent of them
good people who are public servants who
are trying to bring law and order to
these cities and I'll tell you this
whether you see this in Tampa or you see
it somewhere in Wisconsin or Seattle or
New York or anywhere else the first
mayor who actually just stands up
against it and says we are not going to
allow lawlessness we're not going to
allow vigilantism we're not going to
allow people to be hunted down on the
streets and hounded in restaurants and
burn down Wendy's and to tear down
monuments the first mayor who does it
and I promise you it won't be a
progressive mayor but the first mayor
who does it will be a national hero
overnight the average person watching
this wants law and order they want a
decent society it doesn't mean we're a
perfect society as I say all the time
but if the choice is this sort of crazed
Anarchy where they're even attacking
progressive politicians as you just laid
out well then that everyone is going to
end up demanding more and more law
enforcement and it has to start with the
mayors and the governor's not the
president and the federal government I
want to show you this happened yesterday
in Washington DC it's despicable attack
Android Mitchell of MSNBC was
interviewing Eleanor Holmes Norton she's
the representative for the District of
Columbia when somebody comes out of the
blue and tries to get them listen to
what happened next
and so in case you couldn't hear that
and you're listening on radio today the
question was where's the police when you
need them well I have a lot of questions
about that video where the police is I
guess somewhere in the top five but
putting aside the specifics look I had
former New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
on my show this week and I asked him
about what he would do if he was mayor
and people were setting up barricades
and trying to create their own state or
city or autonomous zone in his city and
and he said what I think absolutely is
the right answer he said you know what
they would put up those barricades once
because the second they put it up they
wouldn't have a chance to put it up
again meaning he would send in the
police and that would be it again that
is what everyone wants the mayor of
Seattle in my opinion should be recalled
or at the very least voted out I know a
lot of people in the Seattle area they
are not happy about this and and
anywhere else this is spreading every
every mayor should right now have to
publicly state will you allow people to
set up autonomous zones in your cities
or not and if your answer is yes you
should not be mayor I mean it really is
that simple why do we elect people to be
in office we elect them to keep civil
society tethered and they're actually
the ones that are referring it right now
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell